and enlightenment there.
Okay. Um, Fanatic, what's up, Fanatic?
How you doing? Yo, yo, what's good, man?
Pretty good, man. Welcome back. Yeah.
Um, so firstly, there's two topics,
right? Jesus is God and Paul is greater
than Muhammad. So, I I would like to
talk about um Jesus being God. So, of
course. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead,
though. So, um what is what is your
principle for that? So what what is your
proof of that? Well, Jesus does and says
things that only God can do and only God
can claim. Otherwise, if he wasn't God,
he would be a lying blasphemer and a
crazy person, which we know he's not. So
he says things like, for example, he
claims to be the first and the last.
That is a claim that only God, a title
and a name that only God has. Would you
agree with me on that? Uh yeah. Yep. So
in Revelation 1, Revelation 1:1 17, he
says, "I am the first and the last."
Same thing in chapter 22, same book.
Revelation 22, he says, "I am the first
and the last, the alpha and the omega,
the beginning and the end, showing that
he's infinite and eternal, unccreated,
the everlasting living God." So So Jesus
makes these type of claims about
himself, which shows me that he's God.
So your source would be the New
Testament, right? 100%. Absolutely.
If there's like contradictions or if
there is um false theology in there,
would you say it's not a reliable
source? If there's what? If there's
contradictions or false theology. If
there's false theology, then yeah, it's
not from God or contradictions in the
theology. Not we're not talking about uh
variances, but there's actual
contradiction within the theology and
yeah, of course, it's not from God.
Yeah. So I I would say I definitely
think there are claims from Jesus being
divine, but I also think it's impossible
he is um God at the same time. Okay.
Because God would not be subject to
corruption. Correct. Subject to
corruption. What do you mean corruption?
So meaning he can't suffer, decay, uh
fail. Okay. Did Jesus suffer decay or
fail? He suffered. Yeah. Did he suffer
decay? Yeah. Where where where did he
decay? Cuz he he literally did not
decay. I mean, he died. But did he
decay? How would you define decay? Like
your you decompose. Your body, you know,
decays. It was in that process. I'm
pretty sure his body didn't even see
corruption, bro. See, I like that. What
you said is that God could not fail.
Jesus didn't fail. Nor can God decay or,
you know, become corrupt, right? decay,
decompose. Yeah. Which is exactly what
it said about Jesus. Jesus, even though
he died, death could not hold him. It
was impossible for death to hold him.
Matter of fact, let me show you this.
This is what it says here, bro. I'm glad
you I'm glad you brought this up. I was
actually just talking about this the
other day. We're going to go to Acts
chapter 2 and uh we're going to see that
this was actually prophesied about the
Messiah. He says this in so in in Acts
chapter 2, watch this. says, "Men of
Israel, hear these words." This is Peter
talking after he's filled with the Holy
Spirit. So God is actually speaking
through Peter. Jesus of Nazareth, a man
attested to you by God with mighty works
and wonders and signs that God did
through him in your midst. As you
yourselves know, this Jesus delivered up
according to the definite plan and the
fornowledge of God, you crucified and
killed by the hands of lawless men. God
raised him up, loosing the pangs of
death because it was not possible. It
wasn't possible for him to be held by
it. Look at that. It's impossible for
death to hold Jesus. Who do they think
Jesus is? And he says this, "For David
says concerning him," so he's about to
quote Psalm 16, "I saw the Lord always
before me, for he is at my right hand
that I may not be shaken." Therefore, my
heart was glad and my tongue rejoiced.
My flesh also will dwell in hope. For
you will not abandon my soul to Hades,
meaning the realm of the dead. Right?
You won't leave me there. Or let your
holy ones see corruption. He won't
become corrupted. You have made known to
me the paths of life. You will make me
full of gladness with your presence.
Now, watch what Peter says. He says,
"Brothers, I may say to you with
confidence about the patriarch David
that he both died and was buried and his
tomb is with us to this day." You see
where it says to this day. Yeah. To this
day, man, verse 30. Being therefore a
prophet. So, David wasn't speaking about
himself when he said that he was for he
look watch what he says. Being therefore
a prophet, and knowing that God had
sworn with an oath to him that he would
set one of his descendants on his
throne, he foresaw and spoke about the
resurrection of the Christ, that he was
not abandoned to Hades, nor did his
flesh see corruption. This Jesus God
raised up, and of that we are all
witnesses. So we see here that Jesus
neither did he fail nor did he see
corruption. So he's God by that
standard, right? Yeah. Yeah. But then
then you would you would have the
problem of him not being fully man
because it's essential to humanity to
have corruption and have a sinful
nature. No, it's not essential for man
to have a sinful nature. That's not how
God created us. We developed a sinful
nature when Adam sinned. And so we're b
we're born fallen, but that's not innate
to to us. That's not innate to the human
nature. So how how was he not um born
fallen then if he had the same human
nature as we did? Because he's holy.
He's holy and he's perfect. So he comes
in the likeness of sinful man but
without sin himself, you know. So So he
had a sinful nature but he had no
personal sin. No, he doesn't have a
sinful nature at all. He's just human.
He's human and he is human without sin.
That's That's impossible though. No, not
for Jesus. So then would that not be
special pleading then? How is that
special pleading? Because every every
man has sinned except Jesus. Except
Jesus. Yeah. Yeah. So I I would I would
concede that. But there are still other
problems. Okay. What's another problem?
Cuz uh in in his humanity, he wasn't all
knowing. He he had properties that
contradict the divine properties. Well,
it's not that he has properties that
contradict his divine properties or that
he's not all knowing and all. No, he's
all knowing. It's just that you you'll
see where um he's operating within the
uh properties of his human nature or you
know, he's limiting himself, submitting
himself to human limitations. That
doesn't mean that he doesn't have his
divine attributes. You know what I'm
saying? because he obviously has a
divine nature. So him operating in his
humanity as he is human doesn't negate
that he's also divine and has the divine
properties as well. So so you would say
he wasn't limited uh in his humanity but
he he chose to not be all knowing. No.
So he is all knowing. He is all knowing
like like Jesus it says let me show you.
He says in John 6, it says in John 16 16
verse 30 and 31 or 29 30 and 31. Whoops,
wrong thing. All right. It says here,
his disciples said, "Ah, now you are
speaking plainly and not using figure of
speech. Now we know that you know all
things and do not need anyone to
question you. This is why we believe
that you came from God." Now Jesus's
response, watch this. It's not, "Hey
guys, wait, stop. You're giving me too
much credit. I don't know all things,
but you know, I do know a lot." No, he
says, Jesus answered him, "Do you now
believe?" He's like, "You just now
getting it? Of course, I know all
things." Right? Um, so you see where
Jesus he you know, I mean, you can tell
like Jesus says, for example, he says,
"No one knows the father except the
son." in Matthew 11, in order to know
God, like nobody, no finite mind can
fully know God. Would you agree? Yeah.
So, it'll take an infinite mind, an all-
knowing mind to know God himself. Jesus
said, knowing you. Yeah. Well, Jesus
says, "All things have been handed over
to me by my father. And no one knows the
Son except the Father, and no one knows
the Father except the Son, and to anyone
whom the Son chooses to reveal him."
So just like no one knows the father
except the son. So Christ he has to have
the son has to have an infinite mind in
order to know the father. In the same
way it takes an infinite mind to know
the son as well. No finite mind can
fully comprehend or know the son. And so
um Jesus says the same thing about
himself. No one knows the father ex no
one knows the son except the father and
no one knows the father except the son.
and to anyone whom the son chooses to
reveal him. So we see Jesus giving us,
you know, showing us his his prowess
when it comes to his knowledge, his
cognitive ability. He's all knowing. He
has an infinite mind, you know. Yeah. My
whole argument was based on him being
subject to corruption, but I guess he's
not. So I I don't really have a Oh,
okay. Well, you ready to repeat after
me? I shall do. N not yet. Not yet. Not
yet. It's all right. So, we still
working on you, Fanatic. We still
working on
you. Um, is is that it though? You
didn't have nothing nothing else? Cuz
remember, I told you you can come
anytime. If you have just objections or
questions that that hit you, any you
know, you can come and ask. So,
nothing's on your mind right now. No,
no, that that answers it basically.
That's it. Okay. For sure. All right.
God bless you, man. I'll see you next
time. Sure. I I do I do have one more
question. Sure. So um I don't know what
denomination you are but what what are
your views on the Greek Orthodox for
example because I'm looking into that. I
was looking into the church brothers.
Yeah. And yeah it's it's quite
interesting. So what are your views on
them? Um well one I think that they're
based they're awesome. They've have
already flushed a lot of the stuff out
that we deal with today. They flushed
all of this stuff out in detail
um long before we are even addressing
them. All of this stuff is addressed and
they've done a beautiful job. Um so I
think they're awesome. I think that
looking into uh Greek or orthodoxy is a
help especially coming from a Muslim
background because you guys pride
yourself on tradition and um like
historical substance within the religion
and you'll find that in in orthodoxy. So
I take You're looking into it. Yeah.
Yeah. Thank you. Of course. All right,
man. Take bit. Take care. Until next
time. Let's go. Bye. All right.